Now that we have seen how pipelines work and how
they are affected by hazards and dependencies, let's talk about
how many stages a pipeline should have. In the pipelines
we have seen so far, the ideal CPI is one. We
will later, in this course, see pipelines where the ideal
CPI will be larger than one because they try to
do more than one instruction per cycle. But regardless, there
is some ideal CPI that the pipeline should be achieving, and
it boils down to executing some number of instructions
every single cycle. Now let's consider what happens when
we add more stages to the pipeline. We get
more hazards this way. We have already seen that some
of the dependencies caused a number of stalls to
flush cycles that depend on how deep the pipeline
is; for example, if a branch is resolved in
the second or third stage of the pipeline, we only
have to flush one or two instructions that
we have incorrectly fetched. If the pipeline involves
branches in something like 15 cycle, then we
will flush 14 instructions when have a branch that
we incorrectly resolve. So we have more hazards
when we have more stages. And what that
does, is it adds more of that CPI
penalty. So the CPI increases because of that penalty
that we have when we have a hazard. But
with more stages, there is less work per stage, which
means that our cycle time can be decreased. Less
work per stage means that every cycle there is less
work to do, which means we can do it in less time, so we can speed up our clock.
We already know the iron law, which says that the
execution time is equal to the number of instructions times
the CPI times the cycle time. If we have the
same number of instructions because we're just trying to figure
out for the same instruction set whether we should have
a processor that has more or fewer stages. If we
increase the number of stages, our CPI goes up, which
increases execution time, but the cycle time drops, which decreases
execution time. So the number of stages needs to be
chosen in a way that balances the CPI and the cycle
time; you don't want to have to few stages
because then your cycle time will be too long, but
you don't want to have too many stages because
then your CPI will be too high. We can plot
the number of stages here and how execution time
depends on it, and this is what it looks like.
As you increase the number of stages, the execution
time drops because you still don't have too many hazards.
But you're improving the clock cycle time. At
some point, you get fewer benefits from reducing
the cycle time, and the CPI increase starts
to hurt. Beyond some point, you are no longer
shortening the cycle time very much, but you're
suffering a lot from hazards that are now
causing dependencies that cause many, many cycles of
stores or flushes. So the bottom of this curve,
for modern processors, would be at be at something like
30 to 40 stages, which would be a very, very
deep pipeline. So this would be if you only consider
performance. So for performance, we want a pipeline that is
30 to 40 stages deep, but we need to consider
power. If we have more stages, we are shortening the
cycle time, so we have more cycles per second. And
in each of those cycles, we now have more pipeline latches
that spend energy latching temporary results. So
power quickly increases with the number of stages.
If we plot power, it does something
like this. So because of performance and power
considerations, we want to choose something that
is not in this performance optimal point. We
want something that is also power efficient, so we end up with 10 to 15
stages in modern processors. So again, this is not because
performance is best when you have this many stages. It's because
it's the number of stages that balances pretty good performance
with relatively low power consumption. Or at least manageable power consumption.